I have certain appreciation and
gratitude the fact that I am sitting
next to you know the love of my life I'm
luckiest guy in the world
bachelor alums Ashley Iook Nettie and
Jared haben revealed last month they're
officially a couple now they're opening
up to et about their fairytale romance
how did you really know that this was
what was gonna work and this was the
relationship you needed to make sure
happen oh well I mean for me it was
really a little bit first sight I always
knew that we had something that I had
never experienced before the first day I
met him yeah we are magnets we always
say that one of my favorite things about
us is that because we're similar in
different and the most compatible ways
very compatible complimentary of each
other's like my weaknesses are her
strengths and she really challenges me
to get better at them and I think
similar your weaknesses are my strengths
and I also think like like we said she
pushes me I'm very sensitive towards her
with something she needs and patient and
then it just works it's always worked as
a friendship and now we've opened up a
different side of a relationship and I
didn't think it was possible to care
more about you but it is what about the
first I love yous did that happen
quickly because you were already so
close so I remember who's like six weeks
into like officially being oh yeah I do
not I knew yeah I knew I didn't want to
like I don't wanna say anything we would
say I love you and stuff like in the way
that we always said like your friendship
I love you love you would even say love
of my life before he's that like I'm in
love with you and so but I wanted to
make sure I wanted us to date for a
little while
before we really said those words to
make sure that this was like real and I
want
to be important and so yes we were in
bed and we're just lying there there's
like Elvis eats me up or hotel room
states I couldn't wait anymore though
because we were talking throughout that
entire weekend in before that like about
how much we liked each other and I was
like I don't like you though I love you
yeah and I need to tell you this wait
anyway why more than like yeah and so we
were in bed and I was super nervous to
say I was like I hope she says it back
yeah I was like I think I'm with you
because if you say back then I'm gonna
say I know I'm in love with you about
the world to here right now yeah I'm
totally composed like I'm clay obsessed
with you an addicted there's a couple
also dished on their future will you
guys live together I don't think I'd
want to live together and let's say
we're engaged that's something I didn't
know traditionally now okay well Jared
what are you proposing we just started
becoming boyfriend/girlfriend so I think
we're just kind of enjoy that and work
on a relationship and go from there and
not really have any ideas in the future
except do each other and that's good to
know
[Music]
[Applause]